Hier ist die Online-Talkshow
mit dem gemeinsamen I-Schlüsselbein Dubrow. So schön,
dich zu sehen. Schön, dich zu sehen. Ja, natürlich
Weißt
du, wir haben unseren neuen Film, unsere neuen Filme,
die ich liebe, also ist das Leben gut, du denkst,
es ist ein guter Film. Ich, ja, ich mag ihn
sehr
Walter ist ein
wirklich großer Muppet-Fan, er kommt nach
Hollywood, um uns dabei zu helfen, unser
Kino zu retten. Wirklich, wirklich netter Kerl. Weißt du
, es ist lange her, ja, es war
wie vor 12 Jahren, als wir unseren letzten Film gedreht haben,
und du weißt, ich war nett  Ich
muss wieder tun, was es ist,
auf der großen Leinwand zu sein, ja, du musst
nicht sein, musst dich kleiner und langsamer bewegen, du
weißt, weil du so groß bist, ja, ja,
ja, und das ist gefüllt mit vielen, vielen Musik,
oh  so viele lieder ja ja viel musik
weißt du eines meiner lieblingsdinge a
Der Film ist, dass ich
nach all den Jahren wieder Rainbow Connection singen
darf. Ja, ich habe ein Geheimnis für Sie. Ich werde
es am Ende des Interviews zusammen aufführen.
Ja, oh, das ist wunderbar,
ich tausche so viel
in den Everglades das stimmt
das stimmt ich lebe im Sumpf ich bin
noch da nicht wenn ich nicht arbeite ich
nie ich lebe nie in Hollywood ich
geh immer zurück in den Sumpf ja und was
machst du da den ganzen Tag  Nun, es ist ein
sehr langsamer Lebensstil, weißt du, ich stehe
morgens auf
, ich strecke mich, du weißt, ich finde einen schönen Baumstamm, der in der Sonne sitzt,
und ich sitze einfach da, du siehst
diese Reflexion im Klavier, ja, ich sehe,
es ist wie im Sumpf  Ich gehe einfach so
, wie lange ich das stundenlang jeden Tag machen
kann, also ist es nicht
krass, kein sehr entspannender Blick, schau,
schau, es ist wahrscheinlich langweilig für die Leute,
uns dabei zuzusehen, obwohl okay, ja, wir
sollten wahrscheinlich in Ordnung sein und auch  All die
Jahre, um einen Film zu machen, ist es nicht  Es ist
schrecklich, all die Arbeit,
du weißt, es ist hart, es ist harte Arbeit,
einen Film zu machen, du musst Stunden mit Make-up verbringen,
du weißt wie Miss Piggy, sieh dir Miss
Piggy an  Ja, du weißt, okay,
ja, so heiß, harte Arbeit für dich, sehr
harte Arbeit, ja, und deshalb ist es auch schwer,
herumzureisen, du weißt schon, Leuten
von dem Film zu erzählen, aber ich genieße es,
mit dir zu reden, also ist es großartig, also ja, vielen Dank,
ja, ich weiß es zu schätzen
Ich bin mir
nicht sicher, ob ich immer noch um die
ganze Welt reise und den Leuten von
dem Film erzähle
noch einen zu machen okay du weißt ich
denke dieser film wird ein großer erfolg
ich hoffe als nächstes wird es ein siebter muppet film
ja wenn das AIDS ich denke ist keine frage
gut ich ich ich halte meine ich drücke die
daumen ich sicher  hoffe es tue ich
yeah yeah yeah also die besten wünsche für
y  Vielen Dank für Ihre Arbeit und
viel Erfolg und vielen Dank für den
Agenten. Oder wann immer es so schön ist
, Zeit mit Ihnen zu verbringen, vielen Dank